this was the first ever wimbledon with a
russian player ban but here walking out
on center court to try and make history
was the russian-born and bred kazakh
elena rebeccana standing in her way was
the world number two and crowd-pleasing
on jabba who was trying to make her own
headlines and the tunisians started
strongly taking the first set 6-3
but rebecca maintained her composure to
take the early lead in the second set
showing her speed around the court to
nullify the jabir drop shot
calmly serving it out to level the match
the 23 year old gave nothing away as her
opponent battled to stay in touch and
become the first arabic and african
woman to win a grand slam
but rebecca was nervous as she made her
own history the youngest singles
champion here in over a decade it's a
fairy tale and
as i said it's difficult to describe now
how i feel but
for sure i'm going to remember these two
weeks especially today
forever so i mean it's just
something i will never forget like bob
molly said don't worry be happy you know
you know it's i i really gave it all
these two weeks it's been amazing um
a lot of great memories here with the
crowd with you guys it's really amazing
so
of course i will leave happy and i with
a smile big smile always and
you know tennis is just a sport for me
the most important thing that i feel
good about myself so in the year that
wimbledon bans russian players elena
rebacona moscow born and raised is the
wimbledon champion funny how tennis
works sometimes
the duchess of cambridge presented her
with the venus rose water dish and
despite all the controversy tennis has a
new star
jackie beltral sky news